i'm steven crowder and i'm going to flag
myself i'm michelle malkin and i'm gonna
flag myself hi I'm Bill Whittle and I'm
here to flag myself I'm going to Flags
myself I'm going to flag myself I'm
going to flag myself I'm gonna find
myself I am going to flag myself I'm
going to flag myself
I'm gonna go flag myself I'm gonna flag
myself and I'm gonna flag my dog hello
I'm Ann Coulter and I'll be flagging my
column every week to those of you who
haven't yet heard the current
administration is calling Americans to
flag any fishy information that they
hear in regards to the currently
proposed health care bill the problem is
that oftentimes critical information is
seen as misinformation the White House
doesn't like the fact that a majority of
Americans are against the currently
proposed health care bill this is a
deliberate attempt to intimidate and
silence voices of dissent which is why
I'm asking you to send your email to
flag at whitehouse.gov
again that's flag at whitehouse.gov and
flag your self fled yourself flag
yourself flag yourself by yourself
flag yourself slide yourself flag
yourself do it now you should slide
yourself to send your letter to flag at
whitehouse.gov and let them know what
you think of the proposed health care
bill I won't be intimidated by the
federal government because I am an
American I am an American I am an
American I am an American I am an
American I'm an American and together we
can we can we can we can we can we can
we can we can we can make our voices
heard